well we made it quite clear to the
government what our requirements are
we've been very specific in that regard
actually and of course what that
involves is a tariff free future as
we've got now with the EU that's very
much what we want we want something as
close as possible to the customs union
we also want to be attract the best
labor as we can at this moment of time
and have a set of compliance regulations
aligned with it in you so we've been
very specific than you think of and then
listen to it very carefully about what
we want and you know we plan to keep it
are in ambitious plans continuing as
they've done the past seven years with
seven years of record sales
I don't predict anything different for
2017 frankly but you're optimistic that
the government is going to deliver on
what you want yes we are optimistic
because we've got a close relationship
they understand very clearly the
interest of 40,000 employees our base to
the UK for track your Land Rover and the
they understand the consequence ease to
the supply chain as well so they've
listened intently you know they've got
the message loud and clear from others
about what we want and of course shortly
I suspect they'll start the negotiations
and certainly in our case briefed by
jail are about what we need and what
about the United States how important is
that a market for you and are you
concerned at all about some of the
protectionist noises that Donald Trump's
been making it's a very important market
but to leave a Range Rover I mean that
that the tri-state area around New York
is our biggest constellation market in
the world there we've not had a plan to
manufacture there so we've not changed
our plan to the u.s. the customers with
the cars of course you know we're very
interested in what might happen there
it's very early days not even a week in
that are we so you know we'll see what
happens there I know the Prime
Minister's there this week again she's
very clear about what Jaguar and all
those requirements are for a market like
the u.s. to